I hate being the speaker in between a
crowd and it's alcohol so I tell you
what we're gonna do I'm gonna make this
fun I'm gonna make this short and then
we're gonna go ate some drinks sound
good all right so today I'd like to tell
you the story of Goodreads my wife and I
started it as co-founders 10 years ago I
do the product and engineering she does
the editorial and PR and all kinds of
stuff and I'm just gonna walk through
you know some of the strategies of how
we did this and some of my beliefs on
how you grow and scale a company so if
you're not familiar with Goodreads we
have 50 million registered members on
the site about 400 million monthly page
views which according to Qantas makes us
a top 60 Us website that means we have
more traffic than apple com Walmart com
in Major League Baseball comm and our
audience is interestingly 70% female so
that roughly mirrors actually who buys
and reads books and I think of the
larger social sites only Pinterest
probably has more female slant than we
do all right so I'm gonna tell you guys
my number one secret of success and it
was supposed to come in with an
animation but there it is I so whenever
anybody asked me you know how did you do
this what was the number one thing that
led to your success my answer is always
solve a problem and I'm in a lot of
product reviews that at Goodreads I'm in
a lot I get pitched a lot of business
plans and the first question I always
ask anybody on creating something new is
what problem are you solving and for
whom and if they don't have a super
super crisp answer it's a it's a big red
flag and sometimes you even run into
people who don't even have a problem
they just have a solution and they're
looking for a problem
you know variants of that are
technological I have this awesome AI
technology or machine learning
technology or image recognition
technology and I'm trying to figure out
how to make a business out of it or I'm
an awesome sales dude from Xyz big
company and
I'm trying to figure out how to make a
lot of page views for some company so I
could because I know how to monetize the
out of page views so in my opinion
and in my experience that that never
works what works is when you kind of
start backwards from just obsessing over
what how can I solve a problem for
someone and the great thing about
solving a problem is if you do solve a
problem you can make that the mission of
your company so good reads our mission
is help people find books very simply
and share what they thought of those
books and that's really at the core of
what they do and this does at least two
really good things for you number one it
really helps you build a real good
culture for a company you know
recruiting here in San Francisco berry
is very difficult but we actually do
decently well we have 120 employees
right across the bay in downtown San
Francisco because anyone who's attracted
this kind of problem and helping us
solve this mission finds us
the second thing it does that's really
powerful is it helps you focus and I
think all great you know most big
successful companies you find this
phrase mission driven I'm even starting
to see that phrase bubble up in a lot of
VC meetings where VCS are talking about
finding mission driven founders but the
thing that's powerful it does is it
helps you focus but almost more
importantly it helps you focus you know
as you get one of these things that
starts to grow you suddenly have a
hundred different opportunities in front
of you and saying no to all but a few of
them is actually really really difficult
so I love this quote from Warren Buffett
the difference between successful people
and really successful people is really
successful people say no to almost
everything it's very hard to do so
Goodreads we were acquired by Amazon
three years ago it's a big exciting
moment for me and as part of that
process I met Jeff Bezos and the very
first thing he said to me first
literally first words out of his mouth
where we like mission driven people and
I was kind like what you know I kind of
expected like hey Otis nice to meet you
or something like that but he said we
like mission driven people you started
Goodreads you must be mission driven and
I thought that was pretty powerful in
fact the Amazons collected a whole cadre
of mission-driven companies but the
biggest thing I think I've learned from
Jeff is actually that he is the same
secret idea when he when you ask him
what is the top thing you've done right
to grow Amazon and by the way I consider
Jeff Bezos probably the number-one CEO
or one of the top anyways in the world
right now
he has the same answer you obsess over
solving customers problems and you know
I've heard him say that directly you can
google that he's been quoted as saying
saying that in the press and I love this
quote from him if your customer focused
you're always waking up wondering how
can we make that customer say wow we
don't just want to solve their problem
we want to do it in a way where they say
wow I thought that was pretty powerful
all right so let me tell you the story
of how Goodreads came to be so it was
2005 and I walked into a friend's
apartment in San Francisco and if you're
if you're a reader at all like me and
well a you know you probably have one of
these bookshelves in your house one of
these bookshelves where you've carefully
curated all your favorite books that
you've ever read and B if you walk into
someone else's house and you see that
bookshelf on display you kind of go
right for it and it's fascinating right
it tells you a lot about that person and
in this case I was able to just
literally sit there and grill my friend
dude what did you think about infinite
chest what did you think about diamond
age what did you think about the girl
played fire or dune or freakanomics and
I walked away with ten books that I was
excited to read and I thought wow that's
pretty powerful that's actually that
information is actually gold and my day
job at the time I was a product manager
an engineer at a company called tickle
tickle was an early social network and
dating site we actually used to compete
with Sammy again so that was fun to see
him talk so I said wow what if we could
take all this awesome social networking
stuff that I've learned how to do in my
in my job and apply it to books and we
make a social network where everybody
would put on their profile that
bookshelf that I know is in their house
and not only that but put what they
thought of those books if they did that
I could just browse this browse the site
instead of having to bar
down their living room doors and grilled
them about the books and I would never
lack for a good book recommendation
again and you know I think it's I think
it's worked and so I kind of had an
inkling when we did this that other
people would have this problem and would
find this valuable and one of the first
places we actually got a lot of traction
where it turned out a lot of people did
have that problem was in the early
blogosphere
so this was the blogosphere of 2007
there was live journal and bloggers and
what we found was there was this whole
community of 70% women who were blogging
their book reviews and they had ten
friends on their blog role member blog
roles who were doing the same thing and
when they found Goodreads they adopted
us in droves because basically we did
what they wanted but better we helped
them connect you share their thoughts
about books and connect to like-minded
readers another good thing we did early
on and and this is super important when
you're just starting their companies you
got to nail the product market fit for
your power users so the first thing we
did one of the first features we
launched was groups and the very first
group I created was Goodreads feedback
and this is a group we just talked to
our users about what's going on with the
product and we still use it today it's
got almost twenty thousand people in the
group and I don't know if you could see
this on the slide but I have personally
made for over four thousand comments in
this group and I haven't commented much
in the last few years my team mostly
does it now so most of this was in the
early days and I would literally spend
an hour or two a day in this group and
my favorite moment was when I could just
respond back to someone who mentioned a
problem or a bug or some some thing that
they they couldn't do and say I fixed it
or here it is but the key thing about
this is if you nail the product market
fit for your power users those are the
people are going to say this product is
awesome and spread the word they become
your influencers your mavens and by the
way they're the people who create all
the content at least for us you know
we're a long tail content sites so there
are the people writing all the reviews
creating all the discussion so once we
kind of nailed that first flywheel
that's what let us start to grow to the
people who just wanted to consume the
content
fine all right so I have a theory about
product development that I've developed
over the years which i think is pretty
powerful that I'd like to share with you
guys and my theory is when there's a
problem that a lot of people have you
will find small numbers of people going
out of their way to solve that problem
using kind of manual or hack together
tools and in the trick of course is can
you productize what they're trying to do
make it easy for them to do with
technology to really amplify and then
you can grow really fast and I already
showed you one example of that with the
blogosphere right those people were
hacking together blogger and WordPress 2
to solve a problem and then we made a
better product and they adopted us but I
find this to be a really powerful lens
for the world and now every time I'm
evaluating a new idea I try to think
where can I see people going out of
their way to manually do this now we see
it all the time on our own product
usually in our message boards where
people are using our message boards to
try to hack them together to solve some
problem and you can pretty much point to
every major company and see that they
did the same thing so before Craigslist
was around you know people the way to
buy and sell goods in a neighborhood was
literally through a community bulletin
board or maybe a garage sale that you
advertised around the neighborhood it
was very inefficient and only a few
people did that and then Craigslist came
around and a lot more people did that so
a couple I'll give you two examples of
where we did that with Goodreads number
one is if you're an avid reader
there are amazing avid readers on
Goodreads I read a book or two a month I
don't know about you guys I consider
that pretty good but there are people
who read a book a week there are people
who read a book a day and if you're one
of these people you know you actually
have trouble remembering what you've
read so we found that there were a lot
of in our early research there are a lot
of people who are literally creating
spreadsheets on their computers of all
the books they'd read and when they'd
read them and what they thought and then
in corollary to that is the to read list
you actually still find this today that
it happens all the time you're out at a
conference you're having lunch with a
friend they say dude you got to read
this book it's amazing maybe you hear it
on MP
and most of us just kind of hope we
remember that later but small numbers of
people will actually go and pull out a
little notepad that they keep in their
purse or piece of paper in their wallet
and write it down I would be willing to
bet one of you in this room actually has
such a thing on you right now
anyone that's a lot more than I actually
thought so we productized both of these
these are screenshots of our mobile app
but our desktop app is great at this too
we make it super easy for you to catalog
all the books you've read on Goodreads
you can slice and dice and sort it all
kinds of different ways and have great
metadata and then your you can keep your
to me list which is really the you know
kind of best feature about our mobile
app is now you can easily pull it out
and record that book recommendation
where when you walk into the book store
library you can pull it out and there's
all the books you wanted to read so
these have becomes two of the big core
use cases of Goodreads today all right
another thing I believe in business and
this is a truism is if you see something
working working double down on it and if
you're doing if you're building consumer
based internet product anyway there's
two ways to do that number one you can
make your product better keep listening
to your users keep making your product
better and you've got to have that
strong base and the second thing you can
do is you can kind of tune your growth
channels and for us we've always kind of
focused 80% on making a great product
20% on tuning our growth channels that's
obviously you know an average but so
I'll walk you through some of the ways
we tuned our growth channels so first if
you solve a problem Google will reward
you so back in the early days of
Goodreads I I was very naive and I
hooked up Google Analytics for the first
time and I was like well that's weird
Google says it's giving me half my
traffic from search from SEO and I kind
of didn't believe it I was like it must
be wrong it must be buggy somehow huh
and then later I met a guy who had a who
had an SEO company a company that ranked
well with Google Sites any kind of like
oh yeah you got an SEO site you should
you should go learn about that so then I
did and we got quite good at learning
how to
traffic to a long tail content site for
SEO and you know so but my main point to
you is we didn't go around thinking oh
we'll get a lot of traffic from SEO like
it happened quite by accident and then
once we learned it we did it we kind of
learned how to tune the levers and the
main inputs for for tuning SEO or really
you know work on your inbound links so
give people easy tools to share your
product because then they'll do that and
that'll put links out there in the wild
and the second ways have lots of great
content and that was the main thing for
us so we focused on how can we have as
many reviews as we can across as many
books as we can
very simple second we built some widgets
for blogs so when back when we were
going viral in that early blogosphere we
built some widgets for those guys to
kind of just share show off the books
that they had been reading on the side
of their blogs and we still have these
today they're still effective and that
that helped us go you know viral even
faster amongst the blogosphere and the
other smart thing we did was you know if
you do if you build one of these it's
basically just a line of JavaScript or
flash it doesn't help you with SEO at
all so we added in like a little logo at
the bottom that was just static HTML to
get a link right to our homepage so
everybody who copied this link this
widget to their blog gave us some SEO
juice to our home page address book
importers back in 2007 210 these things
man these were the secret sauce they
really worked before you guys get
excited they don't they don't really
work anymore but back then they were
very they helped you go very viral and
you know if you kind of Google around
hacker blogs you can find this kind of
stuff but back then this was really
innovative stuff and the reason they
were so powerful was you could design
these really tight viral loops and what
I mean by that was if you if you could
get within 24 hours one user to invite
one other friend that's all we needed to
have happen then you have a viral factor
of one dot oh and if you get just a hair
above 1.0 you know one becomes two
becomes three becomes four and it
quickly
rose astronomically and thirty to sixty
days later your traffic does this so
these things were were very innovative
and required a lot of tuning you
basically had to have a growth team just
fully focused on this stuff and focused
on conversion rate through every piece
of the flow and half of it was copy you
know what do you guys think would do
better as a viral subject line
let's compare books A or B join my
reading Network a raise your hand in for
a raise your hand for B I think you guys
are wrong it was B join my reading
network 3x better than a so like that
kind of stuff you would have never
guessed unless you test
so once address book and porters stopped
working so well we found another viral
channel which was the Facebook Open
Graph you might remember this it
launched in 2011 and Spotify was the
poster child everything you listened to
was streamed on to your Facebook profile
but there were 30 launch partners for
the Open Graph and we were one of them
here you can see a cool picture I
snapped
Zuckerberg talking us at the f8 the year
after that is a good good example of it
of a site using Open Graph but these
viral loops were very similar but
different so they were the same process
within 24 hours you want one user to
turn into two but here we're using you
know Facebook sharing you're sharing
what I'm reading share my review share
the book I just started as the way to
drive the the inbound links and again
you need a good dedicated growth team to
really rock this stuff and understand it
so you know to 2007 to 2012 for us were
a lot about this 80% make the product
better 20% tuned our growth channels you
know we did a lot of great stuff on the
product we launched a recommendation
engine which was very powerful and book
clubs and lists and our mobile apps and
what this did was gave us a strong bat
now which is a really geeky way for
saying we had a lot of options
you know we were running the company
breakeven to slightly profitable we
raised a Series A that we didn't spend
any of and this gave us a lot of options
when you have this kind of growth to
kind of say we could raise more money we
could not raise more money we could also
you know this also kind of attracted the
attention of acquirers so that's as I
said earlier what happened to us so
March 28th 2013 we announced that we
were being acquired by Amazon got on the
top with Technium which I was proud of
and you know I'll tell you quickly how
that came to be but given that that's
theme of my talk is solve a problem it's
it's probably no surprise that that came
to be because we were focused on solving
a problem and the problem we wanted to
solve was the basic flywheel of
goodreads
we wanted all users who read books to
use Goodreads and find value in it and
we weren't quite getting that we weren't
getting everyone to remember when they
put a book down to open up their
Goodreads app and come say what they
thought of it so we needed to make it
easier for people to do that to share
that and then of course at the same time
you had Amazon well first they took
ecommerce digital buying physical books
online and then they launched the Kindle
in 2007 which created this digital
reading revolution which is the same
year we launched ironically and you know
today in this public survey I found 40%
of books are bought online but in trade
trade books I think it's much higher
than that so this created an opportunity
for Kindle to say hey we could actually
build social stuff into our reading
device and we were saying hey we have
all this great social community stuff
we'd like to bring into the eating
experience so when we got together with
the Kindle folks it was like a glove it
was like they had the same idea we did
we wanted to do the same stuff and we
were both very excited for that so it
just made it not easy to say yes but
made it exciting so I'll share with you
my two secrets of acquisitions again I
could I was supposed to unveil those but
number one people price people strategy
in
so these are the three ingredients
you've got to have to make an
acquisition work and I've been on both
sides of acquisitions now and I've seen
some others up close so people you've
got to be super super excited with the
people you're gonna work with in our
case I think Amazon and the folks at
Kindle are super super smart and
passionate and innovative and I like
what they're up to and the strategy is
God had said gotta do like I said fit
like a glove like you've got to be
excited about the same stuff they're
excited about and that's really key and
then of course you have to come to a
price that you both agree on and if you
have if you're missing any one of those
three things
that's where acquisitions go straight
and number two companies are bought not
sold in a hundred percent of the times
I've witnessed this is true it always
starts with the acquiring company go
going hey we have we have some problem
we want to solve we want some place we
want to invest in should we build it or
should we buy it and then they run a
search and see how cheap they can buy
something so my message to you is if
you're thinking about selling your
company don't go around trying to sell
it because that's not how it happens
instead go around trying to solve a
problem and if you happen to find a big
company who's trying to solve the same
problem and you like the people and you
can agree on a price that's where it
might happen so it's pretty exciting let
me say that we're now a couple years
into that big vision that we joined
Amazon to build we've now got good
reasons integration and an app on the
e-ink reading devices and on the Kindle
Fire tablets but we're really only about
1% just scratching the surface into the
big vision for where what I think you
know the future of reading the future of
digital reading can go and it's pretty
exciting to be not only a part of that
but helping innovate on it so in
conclusion my 10 is for building a
company you know as I said in the
beginning you got to start with solving
a problem a hundred percent of the
successful companies I've seen and you
saw a bunch of them today where the
founders said we were just passionate
about solving some problem we weren't
trying to make a bail billion-dollar
company or anything like that and then
you've got to listen to your customers
and keep solving their problems
you know we had the feedback group I
used to spend an hour a day doing
customer service emails we still have a
program where all our people do customer
service for a day once a year super
super powerful to listen to your users
and then number two if you're really
soon solving a problem look for how
people are going out of their way to
solve that and see if you can productize
it pretty much every feature we've built
on goodreads UI I could point to an
example where that has been true and
number three be mission driven keeps you
focused keeps you makes it easy to say
no to stuff and and helps you track the
right people and build the right culture
so that's what I got thank you very much
and for a couple questions hi Otis my
name is Martine I'm a big Goodreads fan
from Argentina and I wanted to ask you
if you think it would make sense to
apply the Goodreads model for
discovering content in this case books
for a different medium like podcasts
what would you do
similarly what would you do differently
I would love to get your take on it
thank you a good question I think we get
asked about once a week if someone can
build Goodreads forum movies or some
other similar sounding genre so there's
definitely an idea there yeah I think a
lot of what we don't we have done can be
applied to other genres you know we kind
of do an interesting mixture of the bit
the best way to find books is through
your friends so we're a social network
but it actually turns out your friends
kind of suck at helping you recommend
books like usually you're interested in
other other kinds of books than what
your close friends tend to be reading so
the best way to then do it is find
like-minded readers so you know just
building the community where people can
find like-minded people to them and see
what they're reading that really works
and then number three we leverage the
the kind of the big data we leverage the
wisdom of the crowds and that we've
built like a world-class recommendation
engine with a bunch of machine learning
stuff to do that but it's essentially
just looking and you know like
recommendations by books tends to work
really well behaviorally so if you're
really into World War two books and
you've read five we could look through
our database and say who are the other
people who read those same five tagged
as World War two what else have they
read find three others and you'll
probably like those so that that kind of
pattern matching and behavioral data
tends to work really well so I think all
those all three of those things friends
community and kind of looking for
patterns amongst those first two things
with with machine learning can be
applied to a lot of genres I hope that
answered the question
at us thank you for speaking with us
today I'm a my name's Matt and I'm a
voracious reader I once won a
read-a-thon when I got to the Oakland
A's Ben Wow I'm still read you know
every everyday I've got my Kindle in my
my bag but I lurk on your site and I do
it because books are really personal to
me and I just I haven't quite felt the
trust with social networks that I want
to expose what I'm reading even though I
will happily talk to anyone about a book
so at a time when I'm sure lots of
people are dealing with sort of longtail
business models where they have lots of
lurkers but also there's increasing
issues with like data privacy and
potentially especially outside of this
country but who knows with authoritarian
governments and you know banning books
subpoenaing librarians how do you treat
user privacy and in this context and
also maybe you could give some tips for
people who have problems with lurkers
just viewing their site but not
contributing content Thanks sure so
first I'd say lurking is a feature not a
bug it's actually part of our business
model like I said 90% of our content is
written by 10% of our people and that's
that's by design
so most people can just use Goodreads to
read reviews read discussions find lists
that have been created by other people
and they don't we don't need them to be
trivia we've got a lot of content
already and that's fine for those who do
want to contribute content but maybe
only see have a limited number of people
see it we do offer the ability to make a
private profile where then only your
friends could see your profile and only
your friends could see your friends but
we don't have the ability for you to
make have private book reviews so if you
write a book review it would go on the
book page like all others but if anyone
clicked on your profile it would say
private profile it is a feature request
on our backlog to address that but in
the world of all the exciting things we
have to do we're not there yet
so thank you
sorry with governments I mean have you
had any conflicts where people have
wanted to see everyone who's I don't
know downloaded the Communist Manifesto
or anything like that you would think so
but no I have never gotten that that
request or had any issue that we have
been blocked in China for most of our
existence so I honest my name is Talia
and I think that one of the beauties of
book clubs and walking into someone's
apartment and looking at their
bookshelves is how personal it is and
the sense of community that it offers so
I was wondering if you could tell me how
you've been able to effectively foster
that same sense of community on a
digital platform you know I think the
powerful thing about the Internet in
general is if there's ten other people
in the world who are into some really
weird and arcane thing that you're into
you can find them and that's kind of
what we found to be true at Goodreads if
there's ten other people that are into
reading nineteen sixties ballet books
like my wife is she found those people
on Goodreads and found some other cool
ballet books through them and so I think
that's a lot of what you see the
community doing on Goodreads it's just
kind of finding these like-minded
readers and sometimes it's in really
rare and niche areas and other times
it's in really big areas so you know one
of my favorite book clubs on Goodreads
is called sword and laser run by
Veronica Belmont and it's got 20,000
people in it and they read a sci-fi book
and a fantasy book every month and then
people come on and discuss it and it
feels it feels kind of fun to be part of
a community right now they're reading
Aurora by Kim Stanley Robinson I
recommend everyone check it out all
right that's it thank you so much thank
you guys
all right we did